how many moons could Earth handle the
main factor is space any Moon needs a
clean orbit and we have to take two
things into account
one it can't be too far otherwise it
won't follow a stable orbit around us
two it can't be too close either or the
gravitational pull of Earth will grind
it into crumbs these outer and inner
limits Define our moon Zone a
donut-shaped area where any additional
moon will have to live each Moon around
the earth requires its own personal
submoon Zone and these zones shouldn't
interact with each other like Runners on
Olympic racetrack they need to be spaced
out so that their Mutual influence is
kept to a minimum the bigger the mass of
a moon the larger the personal space
required
all in all simulations have shown that
only a few constellations would be
stable Earth could either host up to
seven moons as big as dwarf planet
series four pluto-sized moons or three
moon-sized moons and then what Tides
might be more violent there could be
different Canada systems and most
notably on some nights our Sky would be
adorned with three bright marbles
frequently casting beautiful Shadows on
each other
wow what a view but